منا لا يتذكر
فيلم الروبوت الادمي الذي حقق نجاحا كبيرا
والذي روى قصه بشري حوله العلماء مقاتل
بشري ونصف روبوتي باسلحه متطوره في ذراعيه
هذا الفيلم جعارنا نتساءل هل يمكن ان
نشاهد بشر السايبورك في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
ربما جواب سؤالنا سيكون صادما لبعضكم نعم
لكن لن يكون كفيلم ترمانيتور فهذه مثلا
مشاهد للعالم البريطاني بيتر سكوت مورجان
الذي قالت عنه وسائل اعلام بريطانيه انه
اول بشري يتحول لسايبر كامل في العالم بعد
تشخيص اصابته بمرض العصبون الحركي في عام
2017 بيتر كان امامه عمان فقط للعيش فقرر
تمديد حياته من خلال ان يصبح اليا بالكامل
وخضع لسلسله من العمليات المعقده بما في
ذلك ادخال انبوب تغذيه مباشر في بطنه
وقسطره في المثانه واجراءات تساعده على
الاستمرار في حياته دون مضاعفات ناجمه عن
مرضه
بيتر طور صوره رمزيه افاتار تشبه وجهه في
الحياه الحقيقيه مصممه لرد باستخدام لغه
الجسد واعلن لاحقا انه اكمل انتقاله
بالكامل الى اول انسان الي كامل في العالم
تقارير علميه كشفت انما يظنه الكثيرون حول
السايبورك بانه نصف الي باذرع ثلاثيه
واعين ليزر ليس حقيقيا او لن يكون بهذه
الصوره وانما تقنيا وعلميا ودمج
التكنولوجيا المتطوره في الاجسام والاجهزه
العصبيه واكبر مثال على ذلك هو مشروع رجل
الاعمال الامريكي ايلون ماسك الذي اطلقه
عام 2017 وكان يهدف من خلاله لزرع رقاقه
في الدماغ لتمكن البشر من التحكم
اللاسلكيا بالحواسيب وتحسين القدرات
البشريه وتحويلهم الى سايبرد عام 2021 نجح
ماسك في زراعه هذه الشريحه في دماغ قرد
وظهر هذا القرد وهو يلعب في لعبه فيديو
بدقه وكانه يملك دماغا بشريا
العالم البريطاني جيمس صدم العالم
بتصريحات خطيره قائلا ان عالمنا سيسيطر
عليه السايبورت مستقبلا موضحا انها كائنات
ستكون قادره على التفكير اسرع بعشرات الاف
المرات من البشر
اشعر بالغضب الشديد عندما يفكر الناس في
ان من سيخلفوننا سيصبحون خدما او عبيدا
راضخين يفعلون كل ما نريد وانهم سيخضعون
لسيطرتنا سوف ينظرون الينا بطريقه نفسها
التي ننظر بها الى النباتات اي اننا اقل
ذكاء
العلماء اوضحوا ان السايبورج ليس بالضروره
ان يطبق على البشر فحسب بل قد يطبق على اي
كائن على قيد الحياه فوق كوكبنا قائلين ان
تداعياته على البشريه ستضعها امام مستقبل
مريب قد تحكمه مخلوقات معدله جينيا واكثر
تطورا فهل نحن مقبلون على عالم من البشر
الاليين